okay now this is an awesome scene one of
my favorites in fact from the entire
seats not canon but what it's not canon
its filler akira toriyama i never wrote
that what don't worry if you didn't know
that i mean not many people really do
nor should they
if there's one thing that Dragon Ball
super could have done a better job with
besides character designs animation
scheduled character writing story pacing
and public relations in general really
it's that Dragon Ball super has done a
very poor job at establishing what is
and isn't cannon the cannon of an anime
is the story from the manga it's adapted
from or more specifically it's the
script the author of the story wrote for
example in Dragon Ball Z the Frieza vs.
Goku fight is canon to the story because
it appears in the manga written by Akira
Toriyama however Gohan returning to
fight Frieza Midway's through that fight
isn't canon it was included by the
animation studio to--we and thus is
considered filler this you might have
realized in relation to Dragon Ball
super creates an even more complicated
problem Akira Toriyama isn't directly
creating the Dragon Ball super manga
like he did back in the day with Dragon
Ball which results in moments like this
oh he's gonna do the kaio-ken thing what
she's gonna it's gonna be awesome oh
yeah okay this is understandably
disappointing for viewers that were
expecting the Kaioken and all of this
confusion spawns from one place a lack
of clarity with what is and is not canon
in Dragon Ball super but fret not I have
found a way okay so in a nutshell what
Dragon Ball super was in the concept
stage Akira Toriyama wasn't really
prepared to continue the manga by
himself and so instead he wrote a rough
outline of the story he wanted to tell
and left both leo taro with the manga
and pain animation with the anime to
fill in the gaps on their own these
notes that Toriyama wrote are the real
Canon of Dragon Ball super and that's
what we're here to find today this
therefore means that if we compare the
anime with the manga we will find that
what is the same is canon and what is
different is the filler so let's begin
the resurrection F movie from 2015 is a
weirdly paced story but it is wood hard
to percent inaccurate Ori I'm a product
the movies
therefore as the true cannon of that
story the 2012 Battle of God's film
however was written in an era without
Dragon Ball super in mind and thus you
have lines like this
messing up penises a Mogan everybody to
comedy it's kinda audacity to know you
start submitting me hiking I see much
done yeah so the movie is a little
outdated and so we gotta use the anime
instead I'm gonna try to get through
this as fast as possible the following
is filler the species that serves beerus
and whis do not have specific designs
provided by accurate Orianna there's no
giant snake subplot with Goten and
Trunks thank God episodes two three and
four of Dragon Ball super our filler
including the Jesus family vacations
that's a shame Goku's body reacting to
beerus on its own i think as a prelude
to ultra instant does not happen in the
manga and therefore is also filler this
however is canon the manga shows a lot
of shop and battles in this particular
arc but that too is filler as it does
not happen in the anime strangely
there's no pilaf gang of the manga
during this section either so unless
Toyo taro is ignoring or skipping
through this story that means the pilaf
gang isn't necessarily canon yet in
Dragon Ball super and finally Goku
doesn't fight beerus in Super Saiyan
form after losing his God power without
realizing it and that concludes battle
of gods and now it's time for universe 6
the entire first episode of the anime
with Goku Vegeta training beers and shop
by having some sort of food competition
and the tournament rules being decided
upon it is pretty much canon - a few
specifics like the food shop abroad
where the scenes take place and the fat
jokes as shop as expense it's also
explained that the winner will receive a
wish with this super Dragon Balls
there's a really nifty fight scene
between beerus and champa that takes
place in the manga but it's say it with
me now miller goku and vegeta rendezvous
back at bulbous place to unload all of
the information and make a plan to find
the remaining super Dragonball Oh tights
exists
she's cannon jock who is called upon to
escort Bulma to that big weird jelly
bean looking plot if I'm I mean Zoo no
the entity that answers any question
what I think is particularly funny about
this analysis is that it also pinpoints
the Akira Toriyama jokes because they
appear in both versions I like to think
he leaves really vague outlines for most
of the story and then suddenly gets
really specific about the wording of a
particular joke like piccolo finally
understanding that Saiyans like strong
women or when boomers chest size is
revealed while all of this is happening
shelf and vados are hard at work
creasing the arena the tournament will
take place it
location of the tournament is canon but
the aesthetic of the arena itself was
left up to interpretation with the anime
and manga differing considerably while
goku and vegeta recruit piccolo and
majin buu boma arrives at zhu nose place
in the anime Jacko apprehends a criminal
near the entrance
that is filler as it does not happen in
the manga Bulma is granted three
questions and while getting the
information she wants through which is
canon she also wastes most of the
questions which is also Canon Goku and
Vegeta electing to use the remainder of
their time in the chamber three years is
canon however the awesome shot of them
reliving their fight in the sand saga as
Super Saiyan blue from the manga isn't
canon additionally bearded Goku and
Vegeta aren't Canon either Menaka
however is canon and his introduction to
Goku as the strongest fighter from
universe 7 is 2 but the location which
the introduction takes place differs and
so there is no set canon introduction
space for these characters visas
transportation cube is canon and the
gang that travels there to spectate is
also canon i confirmed this by
cross-referencing the mangas gang with
this incredibly high-quality image from
episode 32 now that's how you draw a
woman when they arrive we meet all of
the same characters even that weird
alien penguin thing that signals the
anthem of the universe everything is
pretty consistent with both versions
besides the circumstances universe 7
meets the other fighters from universe 6
in the mug that they are lined up and in
the anime they are sitting in some
waiting area
additionally the area where they sit the
written test is different also the test
however is canon and so is Goku barely
scraping by what's more is that there
isn't actually a Canon reason for why
Buu fails the written test
he just fails it would weigh the manga
in a different way in the anime the
tournament begins and the order in which
the fighters from these universes fights
is the exact same with the same results
this was clearly an Toriyama's outline
but many of the fights differ however
bow Tamil and Goku's fight hits pretty
much all the same signposts Goku
struggles initially because he ate too
much warms up and starts getting the
upper head bow Tama reveals that he has
some secret ability but Goku eventually
outsmarts him by judo throwing him out
of bounds it's a very Toriyama fight
Frost is up next for universe 6 and
again his fight is almost entirely canon
fake good guy transforms into his third
form before rushing into his final using
cheating tactics with
to overcome Goku there's a trend however
with these fights the major points on
the fight are Canon but the little bits
in between where they talk differ and
some of the action does - for instance
during Piccolo's fight there are very
few specifics besides him performing
better than expected and ultimately
losing jutsu poison as well no special
beam cannon and no Demon King Piccolo
reference from the manga that's all
filler Jacko's eyesight however is canon
seeing through frost underhanded tactics
piccolo volunteers to step down for
Vegeta and he quickly takes down Frost
the speed of this isn't canon however
the mangas version sees him toy with
frost a lot more strangely the only part
of the magetta fight with Vegeta that's
actually Canon is that he's much tougher
than expected and ultimately loses
because he doesn't like being insulted
which means no Gallic gun final flash or
dome around the fight from the anime
it's all filler the kapa versus Vegeta
fight is largely canon cover starts off
well is pushed into turning super saiyan
by vegeta and ultimately is taken down
easily using super saiyan blue making
Kaba
Vegeta's new pupil there's a moment in
the anime where Frost's tries to sneak
away to steal the cube and the reward
but is intercepted by hit this is
completely filler hit versus Vegeta is
largely Canon Vegeta tries his best as
Super Saiyan blue but can't quite get
the job done Vegeta not having any
advice for Goku is also canon piccolo
finds out that Baraka is a fraud and so
it's all down to Goku the beginning of
the fight is completely canon Goku
choosing to use his base form through
trial and error figuring out how hits
time-skip really works they specifically
tried to explain how hits time-skip
works and why Goku could eventually
overcome it in the manga but in the
anime and isn't nearly as clear so so
it's not a Canon Toriyama explanation
and so Toriyama doesn't even know how it
works
the rest of the fight though is in
Canada there's no Super Saiyan God like
there is in the manga and there's no
Super Saiyan blue kaio-ken times tan
later is in the anime Goku does quit
however leading to hit taking the fall
against Menaka this is all cat it
additionally Zeno arriving and
immediately befriending Goku is also
candid
[Music]
fun fact the vast majority of the Future
Trunks arc is filler which doesn't
surprise me in the slightest the Canon
parts are the first episode almost
entirely although the fashion Bulma dies
at the hands of black is in certain
trunks fling to the Past trunks fighting
with Goku masu travelling into a plans
future with go ah sue Goku Vegeta and
trunks traveling into the future Super
Saiyan Rozier's unveiling beerus
erasings imasu in their timeline that
was awesome the main cast fighting Goku
blackens imasu before retreated to their
past
Vegeta's fight the Mafia and finally the
circumstances surrounding the Masters
eventual defeat at the hands of Zeno
resulting in the weirdest and most
unsatisfying ending I've ever seen in
Dragon Ball
that's all canon everything else however
is filler yep Goku black traveling to
the Past to investigate door Goku black
going super state in the manga filler
Vegeta's gamma bursts flash in the manga
there's definitely no weird but awesome
new Super Saiyan transformation for
trunks no father-son Gallic gun no
father-son talk about how much Bobo
loves Vegeta no trunk spirit sword no
army a fuse imasu no ascended super
saiyan blue no defusing of the masu and
know the masu turning into the sky isn't
canon either there's so much stuff in
this stories telling from both the manga
and the anime that isn't Akira Toriyama
which begs the question how much of this
story did Toriyama actually write my
guess is not a lot before we open up the
crazy basket of spiders that is the
universe survival arc it should go
without saying that any of the filler
episodes between the arcs are entirely
that fewer pitiful arc all of the
episodes before the universe survival
are concluded Goku and krills MIDI arc
that's all filler now on to the universe
of I've Ock
the entire beginning of this arc is
pretty much candid from coke was selling
his produce to getting ambushed by some
criminals as well as his traveling up to
peers homeworld where he against Paris's
wishes teleports using the Zetas button
to remind him about the tournament he
spoke about
oh and Bulma is pregnant there is this
really cool fight scene of the manga
between Vegeta and beerus where vegeta
gains the upper hand momentarily but
that my friends is dirty stinking filler
there's no room for that in this video
we got a safe space for Goku putting the
universe at risk with Zeno which is
canon there is the battle between the
gods of destruction in both versions
however they don't share many
similarities beyond them involving gods
of destruction I wouldn't consider it
specifically canon additionally there is
no exhibition tournament involving
universe 7 and universe 9 goku does
face-off however against topo but the
circumstances he finds himself in are
entirely different in both versions with
the outcomes different completely maybe
Goku fighting topo before the tournament
is canon but nothing else about it
really is at this point you might have
also notice that there are tons of vague
plot points dotted throughout this story
and you'd be 100% right and so Goku sets
out to gather his universe's strongest
fighters who falls asleep and Frieza is
recovered from the dead to participate
but the circumstances behind the
recruitment is entirely different or not
shown which leads me to believe that
Toriyama wrote down the list of
participants with extremely vague
outlines for how they meet are come to
join their team except for 17:17 S
recruitment happens almost exactly the
same way in both versions for the most
part it's almost like he was important
to the story or something
there's no skinny in chez vous from the
anime there's no introduction to Jared's
character like in the manga that's a
shame and the reveal of universe 6 is
Saiyans differs somewhat to that said
all of the characters of significance
from the tournament are completely canon
and boil freezes recruitment from the
episodes 94 and 95 of the anime art
canon there are aspects to them that are
both versions see goku confront Frieza
in the cocoon and both versions end in
them having come to blows for some
reason everything else in the middle
however is filler and now on to the
tournament I'm sure none of you will be
surprised to hear that the 34 episode
long tournament of power is almost
entirely filler it does begin somewhat
the same with Goku Vegeta the androids
and Frieza leaping into solo competition
immediately as a
tournament begins but that's about where
the similarities end despite the lane of
being the same Gohan is wearing
different clothing in the manga and 17
scores the first ring out in back
version - in other words who eliminates
who for the vast majority of the
tournament isn't canon it's quite all
over the place in terms of continuity
one thing that does happen across both
versions however is the frost and freeze
that truce that is mate and frost does
eliminate cruet that said freeze it does
betray this treaty between the two
characters as soon as the opportunity
presents itself but again there is no
fixed circumstances for this to take
place universe 9 is the first universe
to go in both versions and therefore is
Ken Goku's first scuffle with Geron in
the anime however is not it is almost
entirely different in manga my guess is
that Toriyama never wrote anything for
the section of the venire and being the
one to knock hit out the order in which
universe sevens team is eliminated
differs also in the anime it's gone 10
won't she piccolo 18 and so on but in
the manga Roshi outlasts Berlin en 18
piccolo and even Gohan on top of that he
even holds his own against Jared but
don't worry that's not canon either and
some good news
kale and cauliflower do fuse and create
Kevlar though there is no battle with
ultra instant Goku
additionally the circumstances by which
Goku achieves his first taste of ultra
instinct is not similar thus making the
state of Ultra instant Canon but the
means by which it is achieved different
topple becoming a god of destruction is
also not canon but Vegeta putting up a
fight against Jordan in his first outing
with the character is additionally 17
and Frieza tag-team injure in his Canon
and so is the self-destruction 17
performed in an attempt to eliminate the
fighter
Vegeta's elimination isn't canon he is
seen fighting in the manga up until the
very end alongside Goku before falling
off seconds before Frieza tackles both
Jared and Goku into the void so in a
sense it taken both Goku and Frieza to a
limited journey is canon the winner
being 17 universe 7 winning Frieza and
being brought back to life and the other
universe is being restored that is all
cannonball
and finally all the events of Dragon
Ball super Broly are 100% canon as the
script and character designs were
created by Akira Toriyama in conclusion
Dragon Ball super is a mess and it makes
my head hurt but at least now you know
what is it isn't canon maybe kind of I
don't know subscribe
[Music]